all right cora
cora where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um i grew up in saint albans west
virginia
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
yeah both of my parents were alcoholics
um i'm the baby of nine
[Music]
how would you describe your childhood
um
like i said both my parents are
alcoholics um
my older brothers
they were either alcoholics or drug
dealers or
the very my dad was very abusive mean
alcoholic
so alcohol and drug addiction
throughout your family yeah
how many of your siblings are
into either
um
i have two sisters living and two
brothers women
my two sisters
they've never used drugs
or anything never drank or anything
um one of my brothers had and myself
yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
and i escaped as much as possible
and i hated going
how far did you go in school um i went
to 11th grade and i quit
and got my ged and later got my lpn
license
what kind of lesson my lpn what is that
a licensed practical nurse oh i see
so you worked as a nurse for a while
yeah 32 years it was all right yeah
but now you're now you're living on the
street yeah i'm living on the street how
long you been homeless
um since
2016 i've shot my
abuser my
ex-boyfriend he was very mean and
abusive to me and i ended up shooting
him
did you use your time for that
no i didn't kill him i just wanted him
in self-defense
he beat my beat my ass for six hours
i heard the telephone ringing
that landed me in charleston
and i just got stuck
and why do you not maybe go back to your
nursing career
um because myself i'm a i'm an happy
drug addict myself now oh you are
what is your drug
um methamphetamines or we i love
i don't smoke weed than anything
and you're living where you just find a
place to crash for the night
yeah we just
sleep where everyone streets
sometimes we can go stay with different
people friends or whatever
it never works out
um i paid my own home several times and
i've lost it
because i have a big heart and i'm
wearing it with my sleeve people take
advantage of me a lot
[Music]
do you have children of your own
yeah and two um
i was forced to give my son up when i
was 16.
i got pregnant um
i've been molested by my expert in my
what edge for you
from the time i was 14 so i my son is 16
and my mom and him forced me to give him
up
so the father of your
is my brother-in-law that was right yeah
and then i had my daughter at 22
and her dad was very abusive to us
or to me
and i ended up leaving him when she was
probably about three
and for the most part
um my daughter's 34 i raised her by
myself
i was married for seven years and
my ex-husband and i we got a divorce
because he wanted a child of his own and
i couldn't give him another child
and you're
your daughter's awareness she lives in
charleston she's a recovering addict
herself no she is yeah
she's actually works at um recovery
point
because
she was there for a while
my daughter's facing 25 to life for
two people that are dealing on heroin
with
fentanyl that she had sold him
so
she could be facing the rest of her life
in jail
she has four kids
i had a heart attack in 2016
and
my nephew and his wife took
my grandkids and
i had raised my grandkids
their whole life i was all they knew
now my my nephew's wife they won't let
me see him nothing
while my daughter was in jail they
terminated her friend right
how are you supporting yourself now
and i just recently got my
social security disability for my back
and neck injury
after 23 years from fighting for it
is this the lowest part of your life
right now you think
it pretty much
abuse and drugs
is really all i'm having
it's always about me
what age were you when you first started
what did you start with um
with marijuana um
probably 11 or 12. my brothers used to
roll joints for me to take to school
the harder drugs started when
um
when i hurt my back in 1998
i started on pain pills
this is when you were working as a nurse
yes i was doing home health and i hurt
my back and toward my side it can hurt
and
i didn't start using methamphetamines
until
2015 probably
after i shot my abuser in 2016
um
the state police brought me to
charleston to the domestic violence
shelter
where i was in and out there for
probably
12 months or longer
at different times
and then like i said i've had several
homes on my own and
i've lost them because
i have a big heart you know i'll give
somebody the shoes off my feet
if they're cold i'll let them come in
they're hungry i'll feed them
and people just took advantage of me
i couldn't stand up for myself and i
didn't have nobody stand up with me
what kind of emotions do you go through
now you get oppressed or yeah i have
anxiety and depression
um i've tried to commit suicide a couple
times
right now i have a
ex-boyfriend that's a
psychopath and he's a narcissist and
he hit me
outside the head 15 times with a still
pipe
a couple years ago
and
now he just emotionally mentally
comes around me just to torment me
and i can't get away from him everywhere
i go
and he pays people to
buy me or steal my stuff
he's almost two
he wouldn't always like it
so living on the streets is not a safe
place for you
no not really but seems like that's all
i know
um
the workers at the va my worker there
through the outreach program
they tricked me into going to a shelter
in saint albans
and
i just have a lot of
bad memories and stuff and sounds i
don't like saying hummus at all
and they told me if i'd go for a couple
days they had me an apartment
well three months later i still don't
have an apartment
so
i came up here one day and i just ended
up
um
because
sadly
if you piss
one person off in one of the outreach
programs
you piss them all off
and they pick and choose who they help
and they don't help
and it's sad and it's not right
there's nothing we can do about it
i mean men saying
we
we said that more than anybody
about
you know
then
selling favoritism or
whatever it is they want to call it
it's it's not doing no good it's still
continuing
what do you wish you had done
differently in your life
i wish i never started using drugs
that's for sure
um
honestly i wish i had to take my
daughter when she was a baby and just
left
left west virginia yeah
do you feel like living here is almost
like a curse
you can't break free of
yeah for the most part
especially since uh
in 2016
the streets is all i really know you
know um
i've had like i said several homes and
i've lost them because people taking
advantage of me
my so-called friends
and
don't everyday when i'm homeless on the
streets
it's like a curse and you know where
y'all came today
in front of the men's shelter
that's every time something happens to
me
bad or whatever
that's where i always go that's
my safe haven i guess
you feel like with your family history
you think this was almost like you're
you're destined to end up like this
oh yeah
because like i said my family i came
from
a long family history of
abuse
drug addiction alcoholism some type of
an addiction
um
it ended up costing me
my grandkids
and
now i may lose my daughter
and we just started looking after her
i had talked to her for like six years
she played me for everything everyone
went wrong in her life
and i had nothing to do with i had no
part of
the things that went wrong
she got pregnant at an early age
16 instead of me making her be a mom
i let her still be a kid
and i should have made him grow up
and now when my family talks to me um
i still have
my one brother to recover daddy my other
brother's an addict
my two sisters
uh
one of them
she's done things but she
looks like she's better than everybody
else
my other sister she was was quite
perfect just making baby seeds
never done any drugs never drying
nothing but they
that'll have nothing to do with me
so i really don't have nobody
you're kind of just on your own now yep
99 time about myself
occasionally
i may
hang around with somebody but most of
the time i'm by myself i'm walking
streets by myself
and you know a lot of things happen
to me
you get hurt in the streets sometimes
yeah get robbed and stuff like that yeah
i've been robbed i've been raped
um
they just
i don't know why
you know people they'll steal everything
right down to our dirty clothes
um
you know i thought since 2016 i've had
my id and my social security card
my birthday gets stolen 10 times
and you can only get your social
security card 10 times in your lifetime
i'm 56 years old i have some health
issues of my own
i don't know about
you think there's a chance you'll never
get off the streets
yeah
yeah because like i said if you piss
one person off
you piss
me off
all work together you know you piss my
person off and
nobody helps you you know
this is
they blacked my head bouncer expired
twice
i just got it back
um
[Music]
i've had several homes like i said got
kicked out of them
i get banned from the programs or
sanctioned
and
somebody else has lost just as many
homes as me
and they already had them in a place and
they've not been out on the streets very
long
there's a high-end people of us would be
out there for a long time
cora what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
it's sad but
um just not to trust anybody
because everybody claims to be your
friend and tonight
they they still brought me there
they're alive
uh
for whatever reason
just a big name
i used to let me like that
but
i think me
returning
me
and
evil like they are
all right cory thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck getting off
the streets thank you thank you very
much
you